see I wanna go outside stimulation
amplifier
he needs eight behind and I let me warm
where the translator hello and welcome
to Gore I'm safety of our last year's
broke Monroe challenge at wyndham street
race open class winner and i'm here to
show you the proposed gore street race
circuit we start out on richmond street
along to the end of richmond street and
then we take a right onto our well
street nice we burst along here before
another right onto orzel street the
manhole covers and everything are in the
right place for their out of the road
for racing lines and there's plenty of
line choice for passing opportunities
within take a left onto trafford street
a nice we burst past a lucky land where
I'm sure we can have some hospitality
and then a right onto Hawk annoyed drive
which would be a nice wide part of the
circuit no manhole covers or anything in
the road and plenty of line choices for
passing opportunities nice wide flying
part of the circuit right again onto
line street and we go down line straight
just two or door Street and then we hook
a sharp we left we go along auds all
street and a nice we burst probably
third to fourth gear and then back down
a few and on to Avon Street passive and
engineering and along towards the heavy
traffic bypass of richmond street again
a nice we tight senior degree corner
takes us back onto the heavy traffic
bypass which will become our front
straightaway it's a nice long straight
so we're plenty of excitement there
despite the length of the straight here
it's not really an issue because we have
the remainder of richmond street pass or
well street to make a we slip road so if
you came in too hard or got a bit
carried away and decide you weren't
going to make it you have got the option
of standing up and running off another
exciting feature of this venue is that
we have the opportunity to make a motard
section this will consist of a we jump a
berm another we jump and then some
man-made dirt jumps either a double or a
double on a tabletop probably have to
put a wee chicane in the end just to
scrub the dirt off for ties and then
rejoin the road circuit
take me over
take me
I